okay so
what i'm gonna do now
incredibly excited because i've received
these one enormous package and one
rather smaller package from aerotape
press
which are
the fancy fancy fancy editions of
a case of death and honey a sherlock
holmes story
i wrote that's been illustrated and i
don't know which one to open first i'm
going to open
the smaller one i think because
i think the smaller one is going to be
impressive enough
and
but i suspect that
anything is going to be
a disappointment after the huge one so
let's start with this
and i haven't opened these i haven't
seen one of these i don't really know
what it's going to look like
it's
very safely packed
[Music]
so this box contains
okay this is this is
box set
um with two boxes in it one of which is
two books in it the adventure of the
creepy man by arthur conan doyle
in the case of death and honey
by me
um
and
what's lovely
oh my gosh so you got these white and
gold and red
covers
um
the creeping man is kind of a set up to
my story or my story rips off it
this is gorgeous copy number three of
17.
uh this edition of 570 copies of the
adventures the creeping man the
letterpress in two colors
and um
and they're signed by the artist gary
gianni who is brilliant beautiful great
printing
there's a
beautiful illustration
so gary
gets to do his gorgeous edition
the creepy man
and it is something that all
homes people would want designed by the
brilliant marcelo and siana
and then this one here
which also comes in the same box
is
case of death and honey
which is my story
um
there we have
some bees and a queen
and then three of seventy
um
beautiful californic piece
which could have been done
in victorian times gary is so brilliant
this wonderful red and black
bees on every page
and an illustration
with every page we have two different
typefaces
for the story to tell you which bit of
the story
you're in the chinese stuff
is in here
and then
the uh
the more sherlocky bits um
here and there's minecraft homes on his
deathbed
um
beauty
what incredible pollution
okay so that
is
that is gorgeous and now i get to find
out what's in here
and i
genuinely do not know
i do know i only got one of these
so
i think they must be incredibly limited
and
once again
okay so this
is amazing this is
red leather
white leather
and actual
gold gold this is the the thing where
they've actually applied gold leaf
to the bees
and to the side of the case this is
oh my god this is good
okay it's a box open it up and
what's in the box
wow
okay well what you have is the case of
death and honey
done
in leather
as oh well that just fell off and
underneath it is another
illustration um
looks like an original it's like this
actually
original gary
whoa illustration
i would normally stop and look at it for
10 minutes okay so each of these pages
um
is
on
beautiful handmade paper
this is copy ng i've signed it and then
gary has gone in
and signed it too
and he's called me a bee
and
it's just like the most precious thing
in the world that that
hand tipped in color plate
this is the kind of bookmaking
when i was
young i would go to the british museum
and in the british museum sometimes i
would look at these
amazing precious books
that couldn't afford
barely dreamed existed and this is
as beautiful as anyone
it's
astounding okay so it's
huge it's gorgeous it has an original
illustration
with a
secret plate to keep it safe on the
inside we have
um
sherlock and then we have a portfolio
of prince
okay
and it is you open it up and there are
prince by gary
um
all of his
amazing these illustrations
um
there's a
set of prints that you could
frame or just
adore
so
it's so beautiful
keep going
and then
an introduction of sorts by me
um
which i wrote
printed on this beautiful handmade paper
and it's
three
[Music]
it's the three-page thing where
i'd like to talk about
being 10 and walking from lansing to
adding lie
where i wrote it and
what happened
and who i wrote it for
and then down here you also get an
adventure of the creeping knife
so you have
you have one of these
that comes to you in this box as well so
you do not miss out
on anything and then look
you just get
beautiful white skeleton hand on the
black leather
with the drip golden
at the honey
and this goes in here
and that goes in there
this goes in here
and
that this amazing
unbelievable object
goes in there
and uh
that's that's an unboxing
there's an unboxing of beauty i have no
idea where i'm gonna store this i
feel like i need a safe and guard dogs
to look after it properly but of course
what i'll do instead
is find a shelf